انه كل الحكومات الاسرائيليه قبل ان تنشا
دوله اسرائيل هي هكذا طيب 48
51 مدبح
51 مذبحه
وهلا بدو بدا بعدو بيحكي هلا في فيلم
الانذاع عندنا
اسرائيل
من المذابح التي ارتكبت في عام 48
اللي ارتكبها الشباب
[موسيقى]
يعني بعد معه بقول له بدي دوله فلسطينيه
مستقله عاصمتها القدس على حدود 67
المجتمع الدولي وهو 67 وهذا بتنازلات
كثيره
67 طيب اقبلنا احنا بنقول مثلا
27 الي بيعطينا 22% فلسطين
طيب انا قاعد في بلدي بدي احكي مثل ما قلت
لك احنا الان
وصفوه بالازدواجيه في التعاطي مع مصطلح
التطبيع انه دول ااه يتم انتقادها ودول هل
في تطبيق حلو وتطبيع بشعه
العربيه الذي التي عقدت في عام 2002
والتي قدم في ذلك الوقت
الله يرحمه الملك عبد الله مشروع
المبادره العربيه للسنه
المبادره العربيه للسلام تقول بالحرف
الواحد
احنا مع التطبيق شرط ان يبدا بفلسطين يعني
ياخذ الفلسطيني حقه ثم الباقي